david dobrik was in las vegas and a fan
or i guess you call my ex-fan at this
point it seems like
confronted him and recorded it it was
actually really interesting
because david you would expect that he
would like just run away
but he actually lingered for a chat and
um the result was pretty interesting
let's watch
who gave the alcohol to the young girls
was it your boyfriend todd
you kept saying in that video that trish
is the reason
that the article said that you got
alcohol the witnesses
okay two witnesses there said that you
came back with todd with alcohol
yeah so let me start from the beginning
who bought the alcohol did you and todd
go to the store to buy the alcohol
no 100 no
said todd had bought whiskey for himself
yeah
well look i could speak i could speak
for myself and you know i was
i didn't okay no i know i go ahead
i can't speak for anybody else did todd
not here
did todd buy himself whiskey no i
to my understanding todd didn't leave
the apartment and i know the girls say
this and that's so
tricky because they're alcohol at the
apartment there was alcohol at the
apartment
okay there was alcohol department we
don't know where it came from
i mean did you know the girls were
underage
no you said they were either 20 or 21
years old
yeah to my understanding yeah so you did
know that some of them were underage
god i forgot how hard i was grilling
jeff
he hasn't
it's was it who gets to young girls
david you're not safe with your return
bro
who gave the alcohol to the young girls
at that night you're asking a crazy
question that literally
we don't know that taken it's not a
crazy question actually this is really
interesting that david
first of all comments on us but he was
forced to comment on it because if it's
up to him he would just kind of
you know pretend like it never happened
which he's been pretty successful at
doing but
it was really interesting at 1 18 am
from one of the witnesses one of the
girls there
it has in it all of you guys outside
todd you jonah david
what you see here is one of the
girlfriends holding up hannah who was
the victim
because she's blackout drunk you can see
her here being held up right here
and all of you guys there
[Music]
okay to my recollection i wasn't there
for two hours
this morning this photo's time set at 1
18 am
somebody somebody does and your return
was just so it wasn't
the time and place to do that it is what
happened
david says it's not the time and place
to have this conversation when is it
his time and place is never pretending
it never happened
if not now what then when if not me
then who i'm just kidding that's just
the saying i don't know
dude this sounds like this seems like a
perfectly good place to have a
conversation because where else you
gonna do it
you you deleted everything off your bio
you deleted everything off your bio
excuse me you deleted everything off
your mind harassing us right
[Applause]
and someone they said yet you ra you
swept a r word and underage drinking
under a rug hiding it for the most part
it seems
[Music]
okay i don't i don't read that slow it's
like come on
just in time for swimwear week in miami
honestly dude
it's the whole culture you have going on
i've taken measure of drunk people
in the last vlog she was getting drunk
and everything right i said i've been
trying to win
oh my god
those are my
[Laughter]
[Music]
they friends a great picture do you
remember me i was at the phone and boo i
was such a big fan of you i was writing
the trench coat and everything i i
appreciate that bro but
but you don't know what the details of
things i don't look up to you anymore
dude
[ __ ] look at her smiling and
everything about trisha just ended up
being true
there's a time and place for everything
bro they had lawyers
david's lawyers were that's actually
makes me sad i can tell that that guy's
really
hurt by you know the the the
things that his idol has done i wish
david would actually talk about it
because he says there's a time and place
so so that presumes
that he there is a time and place where
he's planning and talking about this i'd
like to know when that is
he made that one video where he kind of
like
alluded to it and in his mind that's
probably that was the time that was
that was how he addressed it you know
[Applause]
threatening them nonstop they have i
don't know i i don't know this stuff
well you act like
i'm with david every day well it's in
the article if you would have [ __ ]
read the article
okay ethan um
oh someone's he's lobbying for him to go
on the hd pockets yeah that will never
happen
yeah yeah good job though i mean that's
something that's kind of it's just an
interesting insight i don't know
i also do find it interesting that he's
still
featuring his friends like blackout for
content
because the weird thing about dave is
that he doesn't drink but he like gives
alcohol and copious amounts to everyone
around him to make
interesting content the guy hid it right
on the head there
here's another one of david david dobrik
car appears to be over capacity and todd
smith may
have an open alcohol container it's
juicy let's see
yeah oh he uh is that like an energy
drink or
like i'm not gonna nick pick this guy
and be like oh it's over capacity i mean
look whatever and we all [ __ ]
but does the dude have an open container
it looks like an energy drink to me to
be honest does anyone can anyone
identify that
also it's legal in some states to have
an open container in the back
it's probably just an energy drink yeah
it looks like energy you know in vegas
and some
you can drink in the back seat which
totally blows my [ __ ] mind i'm seeing
a lot of twisted tees in the chat
um is that oh is that a that is
alcoholic it's freaking tweaked yeah
hold on pull up the can the twisted tee
can we can do a we can do a csi
a comparison oh that's def bro
[Music]
um what state are they in right now
show the can again yeah i'm pulling it
up so
here we go guys you'd be the judge
that looks like a let me see twisted t
back of the can
that's what we need um exactly
i need a 360 of this can but i'm i'm i'm
i think it's a good
guess that it would that it that would
be yellow like
zayn's drink there people saying it
doesn't have the blue part it's kind of
true
yellow red bull i'm seeing a lot of that
in the chest yellow red bull i'm pretty
familiar with the yellow red bull
hold up that's my that's my red bull
yellow red ball
yellow red bull type of guy well hold on
yellow red bulls here
here's the can of yellow red bull
okay so here what do you think about
this
there's no orange at the top yellow red
right
what can't what drink is this we have to
figure this out
this is not a yellow red peach twisted
tea i'm seeing peach twisted taste
peach twisted tea can
[Music]
that's it we gotta hit the [ __ ] we
got a hit
i have something else how is that not it
go ahead what do you got
here i'm just gonna send it one sec yo
that's definitely peach twisted
cam sent me something this is i don't
think this is it but cam sent me what is
this you sent me
a lot of people were spamming this
organic tea because this one
yeah this one is all yellow so i don't
think it's this
okay we have a organic yellow tea let's
let's see let's look at it
send me oh i don't think so because here
i'll show you guys this one this is
really
okay here here's what i'm thinking this
one has this red stripe on the top and
bottom
i'm not seeing i think this this has to
be peach i think it's the peach
twisted too it has to be peach twisted
tea yeah
there's simply no like you guys agree
this can't be this can
the red on the top and bottom is not
present
i think peach twisted tea can is
[Music]
that's it no no orange on the bottom
orange on the top
what do we think about this there's no
such thing as the coin there is no such
thing as a coincidence
i'm seeing a lot of peach confirmed
there's still there's still some
doubters
there's still some doubters out there
dude you would think people say mango
mango twisted tea well
okay let's look at mango i mean i feel
like we're kind of just double
let's just no it's not mango it's green
what are you guys insane are you guys
insane
no you said that yo this is confirmed
right i mean
it's far i mean damn i do
find it wildly i don't know i'm assuming
this is an l.a he's with tana and all of
his friends
but like i do find it pretty
wild that after everything he's been
through that he's allowing his homies to
cruise
with open cans
uh it's a bit odd although can he be
responsible for that
of course it's the driver's
responsibility to make sure no one has
opened oh he's driving i didn't even
catch that
he's driving it's his car he's always
driving i missed the mark with that one
you're dead again
this is a really and i think we really
cracked the case on this
yeah welcome
welcome boys welcome dano certainly
pales in comparison to what he's
previously been
accused of but i think it's
irresponsible
like you think he tight tighten it up
dude after everything he's been through
tighten it up
let's not cruise around with open
containers man
and put it on the internet for so i see
tana put that up there so
shout out to hannah you can't keep
getting away with this
so shout out to david dubrick
crack the case so yesterday we were
talking about
uh natalie was going to do an
interview on barstool where he asked her
about the the dubric
controversy and i was like um
looking forward to seeing what she said
well today
she or i guess it came out yesterday but
here it is
and it's pretty juicy i have to say it's
a definitely a dubric
moment said about david dobrik
before brick
dubrick dubrick dubrick
dubrick dubrick oh i know what this is
yeah this was a while ago too yeah it
was before there was anything
i you never heard anything about
him like with girls or anything it was
so quiet
and i said anything that is i'm the
opposite
i have tons of [ __ ] out there that i'm
not happy that's out there but it's out
there
but i'm like anybody who's this famous
in this well-known
who you never he's squeaky clean there's
got to be something that we don't know
like nobody's that squeaky clean it's
almost like to be that squeaky clean
you're hiding [ __ ] that was before
anything hit the fan
like he can't nobody nobody is that
clean
but you never heard anything and that
famous all together
i can't i mean no i i understand your
point
i mean i feel like david's pretty much
an open book on the internet he just
like
he is so not an open book he's like one
of the most reclusive
private people would you say that abs
someone used to watch him like
he's he protect his understanding no i'm
not gonna put you under the gun i just
see my pineapple i want to assess that
statement
who's this david oh yeah i agree with
you dubrick
because like you know everything was
just a facade
like with him you know so i don't i
disagree natalie
he isn't doing weird [ __ ] behind the
scenes oh really
evidence contra contra uh uh contradicts
that
a lot for example the time
that you guys got a bunch of underage
girls drunk for a vlog and they got r
worded and you filmed it and covered it
up
yeah that's just like a normal average
dude but
um yeah i don't know i mean even the
[ __ ] that went down like
it's really about another dude like
another guy did something david just
happened to be there
you know so yeah that's just so so
revisionist that just happened to be
there
paying everyone to be there recording it
posting it
on that one so obviously it's just there
it's just passive
her saying that is obviously how they
all feel
because she's with them all day so this
is the this is the talking point that
they circle jerk i think that's a fair
assumption and so it's amazing how they
rationalize this way
david the whole reason they were there
was because of david's vlogs
the girl was blackout puking
came outside was blackout
drunk then it was so bad
they had to go back the next day to get
the final shot
and then he posted the video
knowing how messy that was and then
see it's important to clarify because
they're rewriting history here
and then months later the girl sent dom
a message saying i want you to remove
the video
dom told david and david removed the
video so he knew exactly what happened
you know also also it also like he
almost killed jeff widdick
he's great he's greatly injured many of
his friends and as we just discovered
after being through all this he's still
cruising around with his homies with
open containers in the car
so like you know
excuse me dubrick anyway kind of got
pulled into it how hard was it for you
guilty by association type [ __ ]
yeah how killed by association no guilt
by literally being there
involved and covering it up
also hard hitting interviews by dave
pork boy
how hard was it for you being like with
him the whole time and i assume
like in his orbit you know there's a lot
of [ __ ] [ __ ] going on
was it hard on you personally um of
course
yeah i feel like for anybody that goes
through something like that it's
extremely difficult there's millions of
people that are
saying terrible things about you that i
mean obviously
i don't think are true so right well so
i mean that pretty much proves that his
apology was
like literally total uh total
disingenuous
ingenuous because here you heard it from
basically his best friend and closest
associate that
uh he did nothing wrong he was only
there and it was a guilt by association
so peace and love david
dubrick get bent
thank you peace and love this